Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning
podcast for Monday, June 5th, 2017.
What's going on? How I, yeah, how's
it going? How was your weekend?
Um, it's really not Monday
morning at this point. I mean,
it's still my Monday morning.
It's 20 to fucking 11,
but by the time I finished this
shit's going to be about noon, noon.
Um,
Saskatoon Thiede the northern lights.
I just had a fucking amazing weekend.
I want to thank everybody who
came out to cluster fest up in,
um, San Francisco. This
new comedy festival.
I was up there SASAC say,
and on a Sunday,
um, I had like this, I had like
a make a wish weekend was crazy.
I went up there. Um,
let's see. What did I do?
I did the two dope Queens
podcast. Then I did, uh,
I did the comedy jam.
Goddamn comedy jam.
We playing outside near City Hall,
which I called the fucking state capitol.
Anytime I see a dome, I'm like, that's got
to be the capital of the state. I mean,
what, why, why would they spend that much
fucking money making something look that
impressive and all it
is is just city hall.
You're telling me the fucking
mayor lives there. Jesus Christ.
I'd love to see the governor
governor's above the mayor, right?
Is that how it works?
It's like meter maid den.
It goes mayor than governor and
state representative congressman.
Right. And then a senator.
Then the Moto GP level is,
you're the fucking, you're
the president, right?
Who tweets and gets up and storms out
of interviews when he doesn't like the
questions. Um, the fuck
is going on with it.
You know, I watched this thing on, uh,
what's his place of laddy daddy
there Vladimir Putin saying like,
how like anybody who was
like an opponent of his,
they stay fucking kill him is
they've had all these weird suicides.
Swan Guy tied himself to a chair and
somehow threw himself into a pool.
That one right there
is not only,
um,
getting rid of your enemy,
but it's also displaying your level of
power because when you're not even trying
to hide it like that, oh
yeah. That was a suicide. Um,
anyways, and then he's like poison
and fucking people and all this shit.
Whenever I watched those shows,
whenever I watch her stories
about people like that,
there was this guy and
he's gotten poisoned twice.
First time he went into a coma for a week
and he was in the hospital for like a
fucking month. Now he walks with a limp
and he went right back to protests and
you know,
the current regime in Russia.
And then he fucking, they him
again. He goes to the same hospital.
This time they realized, you know,
with his symptoms going right,
this guy's probably been poisoned against.
They knew something a little better.
So they got them out
like a week to 10 days.
I don't know about you guys the first
time I get poisoned and I, and I live,
I'm going to say to the cause, listen
guys, I'm passing the torch. Okay.
I did my part. I'm going to, uh,
I'm going to start making
those furry Russian hats.
Someone opened a little fucking
kiosk down at the local, um,
people's mall, whatever
the fuck it is. It's,
you know what's funny is everybody
thinks Russia is communist, right?
Somebody told me that the
other day going like they do,
they haven't been communists for like
fucking 25 years. They're like, over here.
It's like a small group of people
running shit except a, you know,
rather than tweeting
and walking out on shit,
they just kind of poisoned people
that taking it to the next level.
I believe that kids say it's
turnt up. Um, but anyways,
cluster fest,
I just said I went to bed watching that
as I started talking about a comedy
festival and then I go over it talking
about a guy getting poisoned and
continuing to do what the fuck ever got
poisoned doing. Stand up. That said,
I'm done. I'm done. I would just,
I would send out a tweet, uh, to whom,
whoever poisoned me,
uh,
what would you like me to be doing
with my life so I can get on with that
stock stock,
Rome at best buy you got it.
I'll fucking load and unload flatscreen
TVs for the rest of my fucking life to
not go into another weeklong coma in
stay in the hospital for a goddamn month.
Knowing that there's people out
there that not only can poison me,
I don't know who the fuck they are.
And when they did it,
it was just sitting there
talking to his wife.
Everything's fine and out
of fucking nowhere he see
you went from feeling all of
a sudden you, you know, hey, feel a
little, ah, is it hot in here? Boom.
Right to a coma to fucking 20 minutes
later continues to fight the good fight.
Man, that's amazing. That's
amazing. You know, if there
is an afterlife or whatever,
I feel like that guy's in the
pre-checked TSA line, you know,
just goes right through.
Um,
I saw this little view to video on this
guy who allegedly had a 200 Iq and I
guess the average person has a hundred.
You get up to about one 31 40.
You're a fucking genius.
You know,
fucking Tesla had a one 50
fucking Galileo at a one 60.
Somebody had a one 90 and this guy's
got a 200 so he's allegedly the smartest
person on the fucking planet.
And he lives in the fucking middle of
nowhere on a God damn farm with like a
couple of yaks and some chickens.
And he met some other super
genius woman out of Brooklyn. Um,
I don't know if you heard them both talk.
I didn't buy it. I didn't buy it for,
I dunno what's his wife
started talking and it's just,
they never really made them
demonstrate how fucking smart he was.
He just was talking
about what he was doing.
He's trying to prove that heaven exists.
So
okay,
right there. That was suspect to me once,
just kind of like going like, all right,
this guy is like the smartest person ever.
And he's like a fucking religious freak,
you know?
I don't know.
That's always a,
I haven't found too many smart
people that are like that level
into religion. I have found smart people
into religion, but they're kind of like,
hey, this is what I believe. You don't
believe it. I get it buddy. You know,
it works for me.
So while I have a nice day as opposed
to telling you you're going to fucking
burn forever or some Shit,
I dunno.
Like I was trying to prove the existence
they have. And what about health?
Does that exist?
I don't fucking know.
Um, I'll, I'll send a, uh, uh, posted.
Is that what I'm supposed to say? I'll
post the fucking clip. Um, anyway,
let me get back to cluster fest. I'm
fucking talking in circles here. Um,
so yeah. So I landed, I did a private
gig and then I did two broke girls,
then I played drums at the God damn comedy
jam outside the fucking Mayor's house
in this giant square.
There was a couple thousand people there.
MMM.
And I forgot to adjust this one symbol.
So I tell him to bring my stick up.
This my dad, like the fucking
crash cymbal. The other drum.
We had the crash cymbal
nick right above it.
And I kept hitting it and that was
mission shit. I was fucking up. But I,
I just kept going. It's kind of a learning
experience. Like I fucked up a lot.
I thought and uh, by just kept going
and somehow landed on its feet.
And then later on that
night I did a show there.
I don't know how many fucking
people were there. It was freezing.
It was the coldest I've ever been
doing standup is it just like outside,
you know, safe for those people
who don't live in San Francisco.
And I've made this mistake because I
took a vacation there a long time ago in
July and I dressed like it was July.
Um,
San Francisco summer I believe is like
end of September to like middle of
October.
It's really quick
and the rest of the time
it is fucking freezing. So,
um, I was in this little
fucking trailer in the back,
which always cracks me up about
this business, you know, you like,
I'm going to make it someday I'm going
to be a star and you end up in a fucking
trailer park for most of your career.
So I'm in this trailer, right?
Not even a double wide.
I'm fucking sitting there and oh,
by the way,
Les Claypool Band played across
the way before I went up.
So I got to hear and then play.
I couldn't see him play,
but I got to meet him briefly.
This is my make-a-wish weekend.
I just fucking broke out the double pedal
and I've been trying to play a Tommy
the cat and that type of shit,
which I'm failing miserably at.
And here I am meeting the fucking
guy that wrote the God damn song.
He was cool as hell. His
band sounded amazing. Um,
and uh, yeah, so I was standing
there and I did a show, it was me,
Joe de Rosa and Pete Davidson and I was
sitting in the trailer trying to get
warm, um, you know,
learning from the east coast going right,
if I'm already cold with
my hoodie and my jacket on,
I need to take this shit off and let my
body adjusts. So when I go out there,
when I put the Hoodie and jacket on,
I'll LBR right. That's something, um,
you learn as a kid.
If you already put all your snow shit on
inside the house and your body adjusts
the temperature in the
house with that shit on,
you going to then go outside and
you're going to be freezing cold.
I don't know how it works.
That's how it works.
You gotta take your fucking jacket off.
So I was doing that. And as I'm doing it,
I'm listening to,
to Rosa and he's murdering in like,
the laughs he's getting is not opening a
show. Laughs. And he went out there like,
no pun intended, cold. There was
no nothing, no music. I don't even,
what the fuck it was just ladies
and gentleman, Joe Turow zone.
He walked out to the parking lot where
the hell we were performing and he was
getting laughs that
we're not open or laughs.
And then he brought up Pete Davidson
and he's fucking killing justice hard.
Both of them absolutely murdered.
Whoever was at the show,
I know can back me up on that.
And
then I went out there and it was,
uh,
it was one of the more memorable
shows I've had with like the, uh,
the mayor's house.
There, they had the dome,
it was all lit up and like this Celtics
Green, which was pretty cool. And um,
where they'd sat everybody,
they would like these traffic lights that
would tell him butyl walk or not walk.
And I kept, you know, with seeing the
sign when they were counting down,
whether it was safe to walk across the
alleged traffic that was no longer there.
I kept thinking that was like the end
of my set. It was like fucking me up.
And whenever the, the red light came on,
I'm like, is that mean to wrap it up?
I kept it on, it's a fucking
traffic. Like, um, I dunno. Anyways,
so I did that. And then on Sunday, no,
and then I went to a big after party.
You got to hang out with Joe.
Rosa big J. Nate Barr got,
see all these fucking guys,
man, just having a great time.
And then the next day I got to
interview Jerry Seinfeld, um,
promoting his, uh, comedians in cars,
getting coffee that's going
to be out on Netflix. And, um,
I can't even tell you how fucking nervous
I was to do that because I was just
like, all right, I was joking in
the interview, we're going like,
I always feel like I'm one dumb comment
away from you just standing up and just
walking out of the room and I never see
you again. Like that's the vibe he has.
And as I said that he stood
up and just walked out of the,
starts to walk off the stage.
Um,
I was like really nervous
because I thought that, uh,
I dunno,
I just thought he was going to give
really quick short answers and I was just
going to be sitting there like Chris
Farley when he did that sketch,
what he you I interviewed a Paul
Mccartney, like minimum. We did Seinfeld.
That was awesome. Like I thought it was
literally going to be that guy. But um,
within two seconds I realized,
Oh wait,
this guy did the tonight show
with Johnny Carson. You know,
why wouldn't he come out
here and absolutely fucking
kill it if he just sat here
giving me quick answers
to thing would go nowhere.
And then he would look bad
with me. Um, it was amazing.
One of the most fun things I've gotten
to do with my career and, um, you know,
before I interviewed them for whatever,
all the,
I had all these fucking questions
like I was going to look at my kid,
never interviewed somebody like that.
So I had all these questions I
was going to ask him, you know,
his favorite car of all time, his
favorite met of all time, you know,
what level dictator would you still
be willing to do a private show for?
You know what I mean?
Um,
and I never even had to look at
them and I asked a few of those.
I think I asked him who
his favorite met was.
I forget who said it was someone
from like the 69 series, but, um,
it was probably that guy that
dove caught the ball. Um,
yeah.
But before I went and interviewed them,
I was looking up some information about
him just so I would have something.
I was trying to think what the fuck.
And I asked this guy that he's not been
asked a million times before and I just
happened to see it says Jerry Seinfeld
comments on Kathy Griffin, um,
controversy. And they got to
them, they would just like, Jerry,
why do you think about, oh Kathy Griffin,
blah blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And he just goes, it's stupid.
Who Cares? That was it.
And I was like, oh my God, is he going
to do that when I interview them?
Is it going to be that quick? Um,
thank God, thank God he didn't. Um,
thank God he didn't. So it
went great. Thank Christ.
And then I,
um,
the interview ended,
I dunno, we would just say, man, that
was a lot of fun. Then went great.
It was awesome.
And then he left and then me and Josh,
Adam Meyers jumped in a car.
It didn't really jump in a car.
Cherry jumped in his car cause
he does life. Right. You know,
he gave me some great advice
about being on the road. He said,
when the show's over, you just
goes, go back to the room.
Okay.
He goes,
go back to the room and I go,
you have just want to go out and have a
couple of, he goes, go back to the room,
counts this, nothing,
nothing good is out there.
Just go back to the room and do
you know I already knew that.
Do you know how many times I've learned
that fucking lesson? And he said to me,
he goes,
if you want to look this good in your
sixties go back to the room and he looks
fucking great.
So I'm going to try to do that.
Okay.
How do you go back to the room?
You don't go back to the room.
You have no stories.
I'm going to be in Montreal this weekend.
How do I go back to the room?
One of my favorites to gab eyes
in the fucking world is there.
How do I go back to the room?
I'd have to tell you,
every time I go back to the room,
um,
I'm hating it right until
I get to the elevator.
And then I go up in the elevator and I
go into the room and I put the TV on.
And the second I get into the bed,
I'm like, oh my God, this is awesome.
This is fucking great. I
don't know why. I just,
you know, I think I finished the
show. I'm wired, I'm excited.
It went well. And then I, you know,
I go on the road with friends and
they're always, what do you thank, uh,
maybe go have a couple, two
or tree. And I always say yes.
Okay.
I always say yes. So anyway, so the show
ends. I've learned to go back to the room.
I've also learned to have the
car service right fucking there.
Like Jerry, it was just,
it just, just like his act,
there was no fat on him fucking leaving
the stage, going to the dressing room,
getting his shit. And he just walked right
out and I said, I go, yeah, of course.
I go look at it. Look, this is how you
do your life. The fucking cars ready.
My guys,
I don't know where the fuck he gives.
And he just laughed and he just
got in his car and it was over. So
I usually don't have any sort of a car
service. I usually just walk out. Okay.
So the reason why I have a car service
was because I had tickets to go to the
game, to the NBA finals. My
make a wish weekend continuous.
So my car guy goes,
yeah, I'm fucking dude.
I'm fucking daft to street
and the car garage. And I
go, all right, so right here,
I told him where we were at.
Come to the stage door.
The dude comes to the stage door on foot,
then walk this back to the fucking car
show ended at three 45 to final,
started at five o'clock so I'm like,
what the fuck man? So we walked all
the way over to this parking garage,
got in the elevator,
went downstairs and wait.
I'm in the parking garage with the crowd.
It's the most anti show business thing
ever. It's the most anti Elvis left.
The fucking building was fucking
pedestrian. It was shameful.
I should've had my urine
show business card revoked.
So we get in the car and was sitting in
the traffic with the fucking crowd to
get out of the parking garage. Nothing
VIP about a complete fucking moron.
I am. So we ended up, uh,
me and Josh were riding in the car over
and which is laughing African dude,
but going to the fucking NBA finals,
finals, I whatever the fuck you saying.
And um,
and we had a couple of cigars and we
said to the guy who turned out to be the
greatest driver wherever, we
were like, dude, is it okay if
I don't get the guy in trouble?
He may or may not allegedly
have let us smoke cigar,
the cigar in the back of the car. And, um,
we ended up getting to the finals and uh,
we missed about half of the first quarter
and it's just one of those things like,
I can't believe I'm here. And,
um, I love that fucking arena.
It's going to be a shame
when they leave it.
I'm going to tell warrior fans right now,
enjoy that arena.
Cause your next arena is
not going to be that loud.
The new ones that never that loud,
because they build in all of those
luxury boxes and everything is just so
fucking big and far away from
the court. Um, but anyways,
so we go to the game and,
um, we're watching the game
and it's fucking, you know,
it's great through about the first two
and a half quarters and then the worry
just start pulling away.
And I got to tell you,
as a fan of sport and
competition that Kevin Durant,
the allowing Kevin Duran
to go to the warriors was,
that's out of all those things.
Lebron going to Miami, uh,
fucking Kevin Garnett and Ray
Allen going to the Celtics,
Shaq and Phil Jackson go into the Lakers.
This one might be the worst
one because at least like,
like Shaq and, and Phil Jackson,
that was a bad time. But still,
you still had like the Spurs, they
attempt Duncan, David Robinson, you know,
you still had something
to compete with. And, um,
you know,
with the Celtics when we won,
we still the beat the fucking Lakers
and God knows they always had 9 million
fucking free agents and even the fucking
heat that first year they lost to the
mavericks. But this one, it was just like,
I'm trying to think of an analogy to can
be be like if Matt Magic Johnson join
the uh,
the Celtics or Larry Bird join the Lakers
after the 1985 championship when we
lost to him in the finals, he just
joined the fucking Lakers. Um,
okay.
I kind of,
yeah,
it just felt it felt fucking dirty
when I was watching it going like,
this just doesn't feel
good. It's just, I dunno,
I wasn't an NBA final game
and I was actually bored,
which is funny because I,
I thought when I was at home I didn't
know what the warrior fans were chanting
when they was saying Warriors, warriors.
I thought they were chanting boring,
boring.
I literally thought that that's what they
were saying because there was so much
look at last years.
Okay.
Western conference finals,
that was fucking unbelievable.
That seven game series with the thunder
and the warriors and then you look at
last year's NBA final was fucking amazing.
Went seven games and was one in
the last second by the Cavaliers.
It was incredible basketball.
Incredible level of competition.
Okay.
It was amazing.
And then, I dunno, I don't understand.
Well how the Chris Paul
trade was bad for basketball,
but Kevin Durant going to the warriors
and then just watching him
puffing their chests out,
punching it fucking chess and the crowd
going crazy as if they don't realize
what they're watching.
Like acting as though like,
yeah man, this year is our
year. Last year you beat us.
But you know what? We dug down
deeper now. You didn't, you didn't.
You picked up the best guy that almost
fucking beat you last year and added a t
a team. It was like, I don't know.
Every time they get to within three to
five points, what's, I have to tell you,
it's pretty fucking amazing when
you're playing a team didn't,
haven't even lost the game yet.
They've lost one game since February
and they were already
playing like that before.
They had Kevin Durant's so I'm not
trying to rain on people's parade here or
anything,
but uh,
I really don't have anything to say
about the game other than I will for me.
I watched sports to watch competition.
I don't watch it to watch a lay up.
Um,
I mean the fact that they have
all of those guys and then,
then they can rotate them out and
when they are, Lebron is sitting down,
they got another two Lebron's
still out there. It's just fucking,
I dunno, there was a lot, I
dunno, there was a lot of like,
I just couldn't believe I didn't
hear one warrior fan address it.
You know, at some point just kind
of be like, yes, it's kind of a,
okay.
I mean any Celtic fans out there, you
didn't feel like, dude, what the fuck?
That year in 2000 we were like in last
place and then Kevin Mchale is in the
front office of the Timberwolves and
trades away. Kevin Garnett for nothing.
A former Celtic does that to the
Timberwolves like that should have been
investigated the same way. The power
is salt trade. When, what's his face?
Jerry West was in the front
office of the Grizzlies. Yeah.
We'll give you power. Go Saul for
his fucking brother who's now good,
but he wasn't back then. It's
a horrible fucking trade. Um,
those were bad enough, but I think this
is the worst one ever. Like this is, um,
I'm still holding out.
I have to root for the Cavaliers.
I'm still rooting for the fact
that they can somehow, uh,
you know,
obviously they've got to win the next
one most obvious fucking statement ever.
But um,
yeah,
I got to tell you from about halfway
through the third coordinate started
pulling away and then the Cavaliers
kept fighting back and they,
and they just had, it was, it
was ridiculous. It was like,
I don't know,
I just walked out of there going like,
that felt like a fucking regular season
game. I didn't feel like, I dunno.
I Dunno.
Okay.
I don't know how to Fuck Dick.
Somebody explained to me what the
competition, like as a warrior fan,
you're going to look at that and just
be like, yeah, man, that feels good.
And you have to be honest with yourself.
Warrior fans weren't you guys bitching it?
Lebron when he went to Miami
and he won two down there,
right once saying that's fucking bullshit
and to pile on team now. Now you,
if you were,
you got to say that about your own
fucking team and I didn't eat that once.
I just saw everybody fucking walking
around thumping their chest like this was
the greatest fucking thing ever.
You know what else is funny too,
I really think is hilarious is when the
little kids come out and they do their
dance routines,
that aggressive hip hop dancing.
It's the funniest shit ever to me.
Like what dancing has become.
It's like you're literally sitting
there like a little kid dance.
When I was a kid. It was
cute. It was adorable.
Now you just sitting there like this,
does this kid want to fight me? He,
I think his six year old
is squaring off with me.
This whole fucking new generation where
everybody's just walking around like
they're these gods.
I don't know what the fuck that is about
these fucking Instagram douchebags who
are trying to be inspirational people.
Is this show enough that fucking abs like,
like they're trying to help you by
showing off their beauty and their own
success and standing in front of
private jets holding up a wad of cash.
I just for the fucking life of me,
I can't understand why that behavior
isn't ridiculed and why it's actually like
aspired to.
Okay.
Go out and get yours.
So fuckings get what?
A bunch of fucking shoes. I don't know.
Oh God. I'm just a crabby old man.
I have to tell you.
Um,
if the Cleveland Cavaliers and somehow
signed a giant free agent at the level of
Kevin Durant,
yeah,
then I think this would be probably
the greatest NBA finals ever.
Cause it would be like to
hall of fame fucking teams.
Okay.
Going at it with each other.
Um,
okay.
And then even if I, you know,
I always hated that fucking,
you know, I, I hate the super
teams is you can obviously tell,
but at least if you have two of them
going at it, then it becomes interesting.
Like back in the day
when the, uh, roid it up,
free agent red sox went up against
the roid it up free agent Yankees.
I know it was bad for baseball,
but at least there was, I dunno,
there was another write it up,
free agency fucking team out there.
This is just like,
um,
okay.
I Dunno,
I just don't understand how you play a
team that has the talent that Lebron has
and it's like fucking child's play
because you've got this other,
this fucking juggernaut you
just signed in a, I dunno,
it was weird. It was a weird feeling
leaving there. So I think I've, I fucking,
okay.
I Dunno.
I think that was a little too long.
It's probably talked about it too long,
but like,
I was so excited to go to the
fucking game and then you just,
it would've been nice if one warrior
fan when like, yeah, you know,
it's kind of bullshit, but uh,
you know, you Brian did in Miami,
so does that kind of make
it okay? I mean a, Hey,
do you know that guy touched a kid? So why
can't we touch a kid? Right. It doesn't,
isn't that how it works? Isn't
it? How it works? Yeah, I will.
I was joking with Josh.
I've got two that felt dirty
and then I also have to, to, I absolutely
fucking cannot stand the west coast,
the west coast fucking, um, sports
fan. I just cannot stand them.
I did not hear one intelligent thing
yelled during the game. I mean, their,
their, their commentary is
different reads of, Oh shit. Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, that's it. Nobody fucking
seems to know what's going on.
There was one guy behind me going on.
I never seen the calves come out with
this lineup. Oh, they're going big.
There was a couple of people,
but everybody else was just
fucking mouth breathers.
Just waiting for the ball to go
through the net to be like, oh shit.
They don't want no, no, I'm sorry.
It did meet the fucking blow.
Cheers here. All right. I'm all right.
I'm done fucking whining about that shit,
but it is bullshit. It is. I
actually heard, this is what it,
and this is a fucking
west coast sports fan.
I went into the bathroom and somebody
yelled out with two championships going on
three and somebody goes two and a half.
We got two and a half.
I don't know if he was saying like they
should've got it called a championship
last year or there already
racking this one up.
Okay.
Because they already fucking, we're
going to win game two. I don't know.
I don't fucking know. I
have no, I have no idea.
I hope that that's what
that guy was saying. Um,
do you think I shit on the
whole fucking thing long enough.
I really didn't think it
was going to go that long.
I'm already fucking 28 minutes in.
All right,
let's do a little bit of advertising
here. Oh, by the way, uh, rest in peace,
blue apron, blue apron decided not to, uh,
continue advertising with me
because I said, um, you know,
when they were reading, I was
reading the copy and since, you know,
when you have fresh ingredients,
food tastes better.
And I was like really fresh
and green tastes better.
That's the reason they're claiming
that they, they, they stop, um,
wanting to advertise in the podcast.
Not because six weeks ago I read
that story where they were, you know,
going to farmer's markets, trying
to box out the little man, you know?
I know that's what it was. I know
that they just were like, well,
we can't do it now or he's
going to bring that shit up,
that filthy shit that we
allegedly did up again.
So we're just going to wait and we're
going to wait for him to do one fucking
read that we don't like and then we're
going to be out. Come on blue apron.
How dumb do you think I am? Huh? Stop
going down to farm farmer's markets,
allegedly,
you know,
do you want John Cougar? Mellencamp do
you have to write another fucking song?
Is that, what the hell are you
going after? All right, here's our,
here's our old friends. They don't
give a how I read these, these,
I like these guys.
This is all zip
recruiter. Are you hiring? Do you know
where to post your job? Well are Ya,
do you know where to post your
job to find? You know what?
I got to start this read over again.
You know what? I was just thinking.
I bet if I turned on ESPN
when you turn on Espn,
you know if and when the
warriors win the championship it,
I bet those fucking guys, they're
not going to address it on any level.
They're going to be like, where
do me gay? Which 60 to know?
Where do you put there? To the pit.
You'd have various team to fall time.
I mean even the 96 balls laws,
two games it you're done.
They're going to do that and they will
never address of fucking ridiculous it is.
And how bad for basketball it was.
That Durant left the thunder
just to fucking go pile
on fucking pile on.
Anyways. All right. All Zip
recruiter. Are you hiring? Yeah.
Is that what you're doing?
Do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates?
Talk about the challenge of finding great
talent and slash or the importance of
finding great talent to succeed
to a successful business.
Oh, I got to tell you,
you know, when I walked down the
street with my sandwich board going,
who's talented? You know, it's really
hard and I always think, you know,
I wish there was a better way,
you know, because you know,
in order to win you got to fucking
have all the best guys on one team.
So they win by 30 every night. Um, dude,
you realize to fucking cavalier scored
63 or 64 points in the first half and
they was still down by five. I
mean, what are you going to do?
You score of 64 65 points?
Usually up by 10 or 15
how's zip recruiter is
different with ZipRecruiter?
You can post it notes and this is what
the west coast sports fans just going to
say hater.
That's all they got.
I don't know if it's cause they get up
three hours later than people on the east
coast, but they, I know they just
baked their brains in the sun,
but I don't know if fun. I'll
tell you though, rough out here.
You know how'd zip recruiter
is different with ZipRecruiter?
You can post your job to 100 plus
job sites with just one click.
Then their powerful technology efficiently
matches the right people to do your
job better than anyone else.
That's why zip
recruiter is different.
Unlike other job sites, zip
doesn't depend on candidates
finding you. It finds them. In fact,
over 80% of jobs posted on ZipRecruiter
get a qualified candidate in just 24
hours. No juggling emails
or calls to your office.
Simply screen rate and manage candidates
all in one place with ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use dashboard.
Find out today why zip
has been used by businesses of all sizes.
To find the most qualified job candidates
in a meet with immediate results.
And right now my listeners can post jobs
on Ziprecruiter for free. That's right.
Free by just going to
ziprecruiter.com/bird that's
ziprecruiter.com/bar one more
time for free.
Go to zip.com
um,
all right.
How many more of these fuck and things
you know I should piss off more people.
I could fly through this part
of the podcast. All right,
what do we got here? Oh,
dollar shave club.
Dollar Shave Club is this smarter choice.
You get a great shave at a great price.
Conveniently delivered right to your door.
Do you want to stop nick?
Your balls when you shave him? You no
longer have to Schlep to a store to do it.
Buy a cheaper it disposable razor that
gave you a cheap shave or spend a fortune
on razors with gimmicky shaving you didn't
need. You don't need to do that shit.
And when you use dollar Shave
Club's executive Raiders,
a razor with their doctor
cabbies easy shea.
Okay.
The blade gently glides across
giving you the smooth shave.
Gently glides over your
ball bag down to your taint.
How do you guys shave your balls?
Do you go from asshole up to the ball bag?
Do you come up and over the horizon as
the Sun rising or setting over your ball
bag?
Uh,
talk to cow Dr Carver's shave butter is
transparent for a more precise shave,
helps prevent ingrown hairs and fights.
Razor bumps.
Make the smarter choice by joining
Dollar Shave Club for a limited time.
New members can get their first month of
the executive razor with their tube of
doctor KVCC shape, but only for
$5 with free shipping. After that,
the razors are just a few bucks a month.
That's a $15 value for only five bucks.
There's no hidden fees, no
commitments. Cancel anytime you like.
You can only get this offer
exclusively@dollarshaveclub.com
slash bird that's
dollar shave club.com/burr oh shit.
Pro Flowers. This is the last
one. I'm going to read that.
I'm going to go back to the podcast and
I read these other three later plur pro
flowers.
Have you ever forgotten your anniversary?
If you're nodding. Yup. Um,
you're lying. What? Have you ever
forgotten your anniversary? If you're not,
if you're not nodding yes,
you're lying.
Okay.
The fuck are you talking about?
Well,
I guess I've forgotten
mining that I booked shows,
not realizing it was my anniversary.
I don't think about my anniversary
tilts coming up anyways. You know the,
those people that are just hard to
shop for, like your wife for your,
your anniversary or your sister for
a birthday. It's still worst thing.
Trying to get that perfect
gift a, you know, they'll,
I'll try and get that gift a,
you know, they'll like and be,
won't cost an arm and a leg. Well,
I'm going to make it easy for you.
Just get them a bunch of fucking
flowers. It goes, sweetheart,
thanks for being and you pro flowers.
You have a deli is my goto for flowers.
They're fresh priced right and our
perfect gift for literally anyone I pro
flowers. You got to stop acting like
this is the only thing you got to do.
Pro Flowers is to perfect a cutera
mall to something else that you get.
A woman wants something thoughtful
and they definitely want flowers.
You have to fucking get them flowers.
But she also got, again, something else.
I don't give a fuck if you go
down and get him a zag nut bar.
The fact that you got in the car or you
were in a grocery store and he's thought
about them and you get them flowers.
Bam. That's it. All right. That's it.
And it, guess what about
these flowers? They're fresh,
they're priced right and our perfect
gift for literally anyone. They're fresh.
Yeah, they run off somebodies
freshly dug grave and they delay.
They get delivered straight to your
res Sipion store. How easy is that?
And right now, pro flowers as a
special offer for our listeners,
get $10 off your purchase of $29 or more.
This deal works on bestselling
gifts like a hundred blooms bouquet,
a dozen red roses,
or even their total quality unique
plant gifts to snag this great deal.
Just go to proflowers.com and enter
the code [inaudible] at checkout.
So right now, get $10 off your
first purchase of $29 a more.
It pro flowers,
but this deal definitely won't last long.
Just go to proflowers.com and enter
Promo Code [inaudible] at checkout to get
this special deal.
This is great to have you have someone
in your life that's on the other side of
the fucking country. You know
what I mean? Big Bank. Boom.
It's right there and it's like
you thought about me. Smile.
Um, all right. Anyways,
here we go. All right,
let's read some questions
here for this week.
See if I can stop talking about that
fucking golden state thing. Hey, bill,
would love if you would find it.
I would love,
I would love it if you would
find it to come back to Sweden.
Malmo gets boring. There's
too few redheads to spend
my money on here. Thank you.
All right. I feel like he was vaguely
trashing me yet. He likes my comedy. Um,
I'm definitely going to be
becoming back to Sweden.
Last time I went through Europe,
I didn't do the Scandinavians countries.
What are the Scandinavian countries?
People come on? Norway. Sweden.
Denmark.
Okay.
I know there's one other one in there.
It's not Finland.
That's part of the Nordic countries.
That also includes Scandinavia.
I can't remember.
It's been so long since I was there.
I learned that Scandinavia was like
three countries and then those three
countries are part of
the Nordic countries,
which included Finland and this
little island just north of uh,
Great Britain. Right. Isn't
it? Something like that.
I will definitely be back and I'll have
a brand new hour if few fucking blue
eyed blonde haired cats and uh,
we'll have a great time, uh,
from a lovely French lady.
Hey Bill. Uh, hello balls. Your uh,
I just wanted to say I just wanted to
send a little message and hopefully have
it heard that being a video
video video graph or myself,
I immensely appreciate the graphic
work in details and F is for family.
I'll thank you.
Such a great show on so many levels that
it all the best to everyone involved
with bill in general.
And of course bill himself a
French fan fan from Patty. Hey,
guess what?
French lady,
Fam,
Della Francais,
Lady of the France,
uh,
of the show is actually that the,
the animators is Gaumont,
which is in France. All right.
And then of course, you know, then they
farm it out to these people. Big Jump in,
in Ottawa. That's how it works.
But you guys are part of the mix.
And what's great about France is if
you use French animators and animation
company is you get, uh, the government
gives a little bit of money.
It makes it cheaper. You know, it's a
smart thing. It's like a Trump thing.
They try to bring fucking business,
you know, into their country.
Like Trump says he wants to do as he
walks away from the Paris agreement, um,
it's just a hoax climate
change, not global warming
anymore. It's climate change.
Jets will change in the climate. Um,
I saw some lady on TV going like,
you know, I th I think it's good
for this country that we do it.
And because we've always been a
leader and um, environmental issues.
Yes, we have been a leader of the fucking
fucking it up the most as far as I can
tell, if I'm to believe what
the scientists are saying. Oh,
scientists if their
information. Anyways, um,
by the way, thank you to everybody
that's been watching season two, the, uh,
people have been loving
it and, uh, you know,
it's a ton of Goddamn works and
thank God you guys enjoyed it, uh,
or have been enjoying it.
Please tell more people to watch it.
The more people you tell the watch it,
hopefully the more fans we get and
then they'll let us do a season three.
Um, you know, and if not,
I'll just have all kinds
of free time in my life.
It's kind of a win win for me,
either white people,
either I get to continue working with
these great people doing this great show
or a, I'm going to become a hell
of a drummer. Um, all right,
well thank you so much and I can't wait
to get back to a France at some point.
Uh, just going to wait till the little
one gets a little bit bigger. Um,
we're actually, um, I want to
do, I was talking to Tinea,
I want to get like some sort
of fucking, uh, you know,
French person over here,
right. That can, you know,
help make my daughter's smart cause
she's got to learn from somebody. I know.
It ain't gonna be me.
And then she feels to teach us in
French and teaches us all French.
How great would that be?
My little cutie pie be over in France.
Speak being fluent. Huh? I'll
cute. What that be? You know,
she's sitting up by herself now.
It's fucking amazing.
She has this look on her face.
She's like proud of herself.
It's the cutest thing I've ever
seen in my life. It's just the best.
I'm telling you. It's the best.
There's no material and having a kid,
there really isn't,
other than your fear that something
bad's going to happen to them.
But I feel like that's been fucking
done to death. You know what I mean?
Other than that, it's just, it's been
fucking phenomenal. Um, okay. Uh,
F is for family. Hey Bill, I'm
a big fan of your work, uh, in,
from Puerto Rico.
Oh,
hope used top to see you
perform some day here. Um,
I watched the second season of
emphasis from family and is great.
Even better than the first one.
Completely hilarious. Well,
take care and keep the good work. Keep
up the good work. How would that work?
You know, Puerto Rico is like not
a state, but it's one of those,
yet another place that we kind
of just decided was ours. MMM.
If I go on stage there too, I don't
know. I went on stage in Singapore.
I didn't get caned.
I'm sure I'll be all in Puerto Rico.
I'd love to fucking go there. Bring my
wife. She can go to the fucking beach,
you know? Yeah. I'll be there
with all the lovely ladies.
All those fucking j Lo's walking around.
I think that would be that.
I could definitely be talked into that.
I go over there and tell my
fucking shit jokes. Um, all right.
Can't stop smoking cigarettes.
Uh,
all right.
Get Job on new season.
Good job on the new
season of F is for family.
I'm halfway through and it's hilarious.
I've been smoking for seven years now.
I'm 22 and I can't stop smoking.
Uh,
it's really starting to affect
my health and I'm sick of it.
I quit boozing and smoking weed,
but I've never been able to quit smoking
cigarettes. All right. And what the fuck?
How do I help you do this?
I tried to replace it with weed,
but it just makes me want to smoke a
cigarette after alcohol gives me cravings
too. You used to smoke cigars, so
maybe you've got some good tips.
I still smoke cigars to help me
quit. By the way, you, she, uh,
you should come to Minneapolis
soon and play a show.
Check out the new Viking
stadium. It's amazing. Yeah. MMM.
Let's see you guys. Yeah. Near the twin
stadium is amazing. You guys are doing,
are right up there as is the wilds.
The last time I went to,
uh,
I went to a,
okay.
What do you gotta take
the Timberwolves game?
Kevin Garnett was still there and you
played in the target center and that was a
shit hole. MMM. All right.
Well they say quitting cigarettes
is as hard as quitting heroin. So.
MMM. I Dunno. I,
I would try to get professional help.
Okay.
I am so happy I never started doing that.
And um,
you know, I don't, I like, I used
to smoke cigars like, you know,
once every like four days or something
like that. Now I smoke. I'm like, okay,
once every two weeks,
sometimes three weeks.
And I really don't have the craving to
do what I kind of wait for like the right
time to do it.
Like riding in a car to go over
to the NBA finals that felt, yeah,
this is a cigar fucking moment.
Okay.
MMM.
But the way I was doing it before,
it was just like fucking, you know,
every God damn couple
of days, like, you know,
having a humidor and all that type
of stuff, you can really just, yeah.
I Dunno.
Um,
I still think I smoked
too many of them and
mmm.
I don't eat right when I'm on the road
and I drink too much when I'm on the road
and it's something I have a personally,
I have to stop doing that.
MMM.
I am. You know what it is. It's
really, I find it's just developing,
I know people say this, but it's
just developing new habits. Like, uh,
you know, if you're eating
shit food, you crave shit food.
If you're eating salads and good
stuff, you crave that. And, um,
I don't know. I'm a creature of habit and
if it's just like every night, you know,
we're going out, we're having drinks
after the show. It just because it just,
your body's like, oh, now we do
this, it's in like this routine.
So you kind of have to force
yourself to break up your routine.
MMM.
And I think you just have to make a
decision that you're going to be stronger
than it, you know, unless you
have like some sort of, you know,
okay.
Super addictive like personality,
like those people and you've got to go
into the doctor drew house or some shit
like that. I'm mean, I don't know what
your deal is, but I would definitely,
I would seek professional
help. Um, all right.
VIP airline. Hey Bill, that
airline with the hot air.
Okay.
Hostesses, um, exist.
It only flies between Paris and New York.
Oh, I was talking about a VIP airline.
We don't have to go on with people that
are going to take their shoes off and
put their feet up over the God damn.
MMM.
You know,
stick in between your fucking,
what do they do the stick in between
your fucking arm rest and that type of
thing. Just those God damn animals.
They should just have a first class one.
They should have animal airlines and
then fucking raised right airlines.
So he's saying there is a VIP airline,
but it only flies between Paris and
New York. It's only business class.
They give you iPads, feed you chef made
food and plenty of good French wine.
The tickets aren't even that expensive.
Um,
treat Nia to a holiday.
Best from France. Well,
what's the name of the fucking airline
do you got to give me the name of the
airline dude? Ah, now I
got to look it up. Oh, Hey,
I've got to tell you how to look at it,
but you know,
I got time to fucking do this.
Will my Internet even work?
Fucking scam at that is all right.
A v I P airline,
New York to Paris.
Come on.
What do you say? American Airlines,
New York to Paris flights.
Air France.
The companion.
Discover Paris was unique from all,
all business class airline. I found it.
It's La, c o m p a g n I e. Dot Com.
1800 bucks, dude. You
said it was a thousand.
I want to see some pictures
here. Plenty. A trip to Paris.
Oh Wow. Okay. I'm, I'm impressed
with their little terminal there.
Micah panic. Not Dude. I
live in La. I live in La,
so I'm not going to fucking
connects from New York.
I'm just going to say fuck it.
Use all my miles and uh, jump on a
plane. Okay. Full revver in New York.
That'd be a nice thing to do.
Maybe I'm doing a Gig in New York and
then afterwards we can just go fly out of
there. It's a good idea. God dammit.
That's a good fucking idea.
Who knows me out style as the wife
about that one. You know what I mean?
You know how that works. Oh, that
was a question I wanted to ask Jerry.
I forgot to do. I wanted to ask him, do,
can you just come home with a new Porsche
or do you have to clear it with your
wife? You know, can you get to a fucking
like, can you just look at it and be like,
dude, I'm Jerry Seinfeld. You know, look
around your house. Did he do like this,
this, this, this echo echo. Um, all right.
Heart surgeon busted for filming.
Me taking a piss.
Okay.
What beer dear Billy, double take tits.
I got the fuck.
That means it's hilarious.
I heard this story on your podcast last
week. His fucking phone keeps vibrating.
This whole podcast, the
phone fart. Wayne. Wayne,
what the fuck is all of this
stuff? Oh, Jesus Christ. All right,
here we go.
I heard this story on your podcast last
week about the Oxford students stabbing
her boyfriend in the leg with a butter
knife and how she was led off easy
despite her psychotic actions.
I have a similar story that
involved myself a little while ago.
I mean musician and was playing a solo
gig near some markets in the popular
popular part of Brisbane. Where
the fuck is that? I've been there.
Oh, that's Australia, Australia hug.
That was the next thing. Let me sit calm.
I went to the next uh, page.
It's fucking hilarious.
Not during one of my breaks. I went to
take a leak in the public amenities.
Uh,
I was doing my business and one of the
stalls when suddenly I noticed an iPhone
slowly coming over the top
of my stall to my left.
I can only see half of the phone
but could tell the camera was going.
Obviously it took me by surprise and for
about two seconds my head went through
a does not compute mode. I was only
halfway through taking a piss. I said,
what the fuck? Out Loud. When I heard
the stall next to mine open very quickly,
I looked behind me and saw short,
possibly Asian guy running.
I tried to stop mid Piss, very
difficult, adjusted myself quickly,
ran and ran out after him only to find
hundreds of people through the markets.
I couldn't see him anywhere. I was
infuriated. It was infuriating.
My first thought was, oh, great,
now I'm going to be uploaded to
some quote. I love public pissing.
Dot Khan porn site.
Uh,
I was really fucking pissed off,
no pun intended from this guy evidently,
but kind of glad I didn't
catch him because I probably
would have dragged him by
the balls to the police and then
they would charge me for assault.
I don't think you would because it's a
guy to guy a physical confrontation and
on his phone there would
be your Dick. Uh, anyways,
a few days later I was telling my friend
what had happened and he said that he
heard about an agent,
German national being caught filming
seven men and the public toilets in the
same area. And he found the
article online. So it turns
out this 26 year old guys,
a trainee heart surgeon on holiday in
Australia celebrating his graduation from
medical school.
Here's the article.
What the fuck? Wait a
minute. Wait a minute. Well,
at least he doesn't work on somebody's
fucking urinary tract him. And he's,
he's, he's, uh, he at least had
enough discipline to be like, listen,
I can't be near the Dick area.
I don't trust myself.
So he's up by the fucking hot.
Um,
okay. This, this article is slowly
but surely opening what, what is the,
what is going on in the world?
The judge went easy on him and didn't
record a conviction because of his
promising career.
What the fuck?
I guess if you're a doctor you can
get away with anything. What the fuck.
So just because you're an
elite student in this world,
you get let off easy for
doing really fucked up things.
Apparently none of the other men
filmed were aware of what he was doing.
So I called the police in the area.
He was caught.
They asked me to describe what I
was wearing at the time, blah, blah,
blah and said the phone was confiscated
and the footage was deleted.
I fucking hope so.
They also act.
That was him saying that I just gave it
a great read. So it's sounding like me.
If I can pat myself on the back. They
also asked if I wanted to press charges.
I said,
fuck yes.
The cop I spoke to said he would pay the
pervert of visit very soon to lay the
charges as the guy was due to
leave the country in two days.
I called back on the day he was
supposed to leave the country,
but the cops said they wouldn't won't
be pressing charges because they had
already been laid by the arresting officer
and that the student had received a
conviction. Even though the
article said he hadn't weird,
but apparently he will never be able to
enter Australia again for the rest of
his life. I just think it's so fucked up
that these people can get away with such
disgraceful actions,
especially someone like this heart surgeon
who could potentially be be playing
with some poor guy's balls as
he lays under the anesthetic.
I'd love to hear your thoughts.
Well,
they kind of have the guy in check because
heart surgery, you need other people.
Um, oh, here's the guy. German tourists.
Okay.
Lodi Tran was fine.
800 bucks.
Sounds like about a hundred dollars a dick
after pleading guilty
to several seven counts.
Oh seven counts, seven and
800 side I use, I don't know,
but 115 yeah, but on a 15 bucks a whack
or something like that on a 12 bucks,
I dunno.
A council of recording in
breach of privacy training.
Heart Surgery. Okay. This guy, 26
a German national, Jesus Christ,
even fucking Asians, if they go to
Germany, that becomes sex perverts.
I thought it was just the Germans.
What is it with that country?
They just ended the P and in the shit
and what the fuck is going on over there?
Um,
okay.
So he's fine. Uh, 800
bucks. That's a pleading.
Guilty to the prison magistrate and
Saturday on seven counts of recording in
breach of privacy.
The court heard Lee had been in Australia
for a month to celebrate as recent
graduation from medical
school when he was,
when he filmed the naked men on Friday.
Lee Film seven men in the space of three
hours by holding his iPhone over the
wall of the neighboring cubicle. None of
the men realize they were being filmed,
but it's behavior drew the
attention of South Bank security.
Who contacted police Lee was arrested.
The police found the video of the men
on this phone acting magistrate bubble.
I described his ass actions. It's
disgusting. The fences of disgusting.
The offenses are disgusting offenses
involving a serious breach of the privacy
of other adult males.
I can only assume the offending was
for sexual gratification purposes.
Um, Lee's lawyer, Kate Mccarthy,
has said her client had been accepted
into cardiology unit in Germany and would
fly home on January 12th is a very
promising career ahead of him. She said,
she said her client was
ashamed of his actions,
but asking that a conviction not be
recorded against him because it could
jeopardize his career and
ability to travel. Mr Schubert,
finally $800 and did
not record a conviction.
Okay.
Wow, man. Uh, you know, that's
fucked up. That's really fucked up.
That's really fucked up.
And am I crazy to think that because he's
okay.
These actions are against men.
You know,
some Apis do a guide. It's just not
as serious. I don't think, you know,
I just think it's
okay.
I Dunno. Either. People were like,
Eh, you know, they think it's funny.
Hmm.
Like if this is the thing,
if a,
if a woman told another woman that's
some woman I guess was filming and they'd
be like, what the fuck am I breaking
away? Maybe because it was a woman though,
but last week was a woman she had and
she stabbed the guy with the knife.
Okay.
Maybe it isn't any of these issues.
Maybe if it's just, if you listen,
if you want to get away with shit and
you don't want to be a banker or be in an
insurance company,
then I would say get into,
have a promising medical
career in front of you.
Evidently that just absolves you of
everything that's really upsetting.
Um, all right. Let's,
let's, do you want to,
I'm the only way to follow up that
upsetting story as the only thing I know
that's more upsetting than
somebody filming another
man pink without him knowing
was me reading out loud.
He likes everybody. Alex,
you're unique. Oh, you're a
special fucking snowflake.
You don't walk like everybody
else talk like everybody else.
Share Jack are asleep like anyone else.
So why is your mattress one size fits all?
What army movie is that from?
Your mother's are not here anymore.
I'm going to teach you how to walk,
talk, show, share locker,
United States Marine Corps. Um,
because a truly customized mattress
will cost you five to 10,000 bucks until
now.
Go to Helix helicase sleep.com.
Answer a few simple questions and they'll
run a three d biomechanical model of
your body through the
proprietary algorithms they
developed with the help of the
world's leading irrigate nomics
and biomechanics experts.
Whatever the fuck that means,
I think he just got cloned the result,
the most comfortable mattress you've
ever slept on. Just ask your replacement.
I love sleeping on this mattress.
He looks customers report a 30%
improvement overall sleep quality and for
couples, they customize each side of the
mattress to beginning of the end of your
relationship.
Your mattress arrives at your door in
about a week in shipping is 100% free.
That's why everyone from
Gq magazine to Forbes,
they're all talking about helix sleep.
You have 100 nights to try it
out and if you don't like it,
they'll pick it up for free and
give you a whole 100% refund.
No questions asked.
Go to hell and sleep.com/bar
and get $50 off your order.
That's helix sleep.com/bar hey,
headaches,
sleep.com/burp upside.
Man,
you know something, there's a better
way. Feed it by business travel man.
It's called upside.com and if you want
to get rid of the middle man, man,
every time you buy a trip and upside,
you'll save your company a ton of money
and they'll give you an Amazon gift card
worth hundreds of dollars.
Upsides able to do this because they
bundle your flights and hotel together for
one low price.
Bundled pricing saves money.
If you're a frequent business traveler,
you're company saves a ton of money and
you get thousands a year and gift cards
just for buying your air and
hotel together at upside.
Plus you still get all your miles.
I mean they got everything in here,
but a hand job.
If you're shopping for business,
you'd be crazy not to check out upside.com
it takes three minutes to see how
much you can say by buying your flights
and hotel together for one low price.
And right now, when you
use, when you use my name,
bur you're guaranteed to get at least
a $100 Amazon gift card for your first
trip. And you can buy a little $80 camera
and go into a men's restroom as long as
you're in the medical field and film
other guy's peeing and evidently you'll be
fine. That's my name, Bert. To get
at least a $100 Amazon gift card,
say big on travel and get a
big gift card every trip. Uh,
I love upside.com evidentaly
upside.com minimum purchase required.
See Site for complete details. Oh, there
it is. Minimum minimum purchase required.
I was gonna say he can't just give,
get a fucking $150 flight and to give a
guy a hundred dollar gift card, I mean,
you know, you're going to go wonder.
All right. stamps.com have you buddies.
Stamps saves you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business.
You know,
or stab your boyfriend with
a butter knife from you.
You got all the all this time now
I can mail any letter, any package,
just using my computer and printer and
the mailman just comes and picks it up.
Avoid the hassle,
man.
I go into the post office and mail
everything from postcards to envelopes to
packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in minutes
online with no equipment to lease and no
long term commitments. I use stamps.com
anytime I'm selling my fucking dad,
I'm boring myself out selling posters or
whatever if I can figure out how to use
it.
So can you,
and right now you too can
enjoy the stamps.com servers
with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage
and a digital scale without longterm
commitments.
So go to stamps.com.
Click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbarthatstamps.com
enter
[inaudible] stamps.com.
Never go to the post office again.
That's it. It's a fucking rap. Um,
all right. All right. So what
do we got here? What do I
got left to talk about? Um,
oh,
how about the fucking Nashville predators
making it a series winning game three.
What?
I hope the Cavaliers do.
What I still believe the
Cavaliers can do despite the fact.
No, I'm not gonna get back into that
again. Um, predators, when game three,
I saw a little bit of it.
I was working that night and uh,
I actually saw when they went ahead to
one and then three one, was that the game?
I can't remember.
Um,
okay,
so here we go. I mean,
from what I've heard,
they've been out playing the penguins
at at least two out of the three games.
So maybe they'll tie it up and maybe
someone like myself will get what I want,
which is a nice seven game
series. A nice classic. So a,
that game's tonight. I will definitely
be watching and a this week, this week,
all Billy red face.
I want to be on Howard stern on Wednesday,
Wednesday, Wednesday, Wednesday.
My triumphant return.
I've not been on that
show since I believe 2003.
I did it twice in one month. I
thought I was in, in guy and,
and I never got another invite.
So I'm finally back.
You know, I'm psyched. Psyched
to finally come back, uh,
onto the show. So please
listen on Wednesday. Um,
and that's it. That's the podcast.
Thank you for listening and really man,
no joke. Thank you to
everybody who's been watching.
F is for family telling people about it.
MMM.
And then also taking the time to let me
know how much you're enjoying it. Yeah.
Uh,
it's just, it's, it's really been
one of the great weeks of my life.
I have to be honest with you.
So no jokes or anything.
Thank you guys for watching it.
Uh,
please continue to tell people about it
and um, cause we already have ceased.
We know we want to do in season three.
We just have to wait for Netflix to give
us the green light and they give us the
green light by you guys watching
it and talking about it online,
which you guys are doing. So I can't
thank you enough. And um, and that's it.
Thank you to everybody at cluster fest.
I had a great time.
Thank you to the city of San Francisco.
Uh,
thank you to the warrior says for
still playing in the Oracle, you know,
great fucking old. Oh, you
know what's funny? When I did
that Seinfeld interview, I,
I jokingly said that this,
this venue feels like an old ABA arena
and evidently the Old San Francisco
warriors used to play there, so it felt
pretty good about calling that one.
Um, all right, Phil, you're overstaying
your welcome. Okay, go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you on Thursday and
that's it. Let's go. Cavs. C'Mon man.
If you beat the fucking warriors with
all their Cuatro Moss that they added all
of that fucking Juggernaut of
a Goddamn team walking around,
thumping themselves in the
chest as if what they're doing.
I've said this for fucking ever,
and I'll say the last time when you were
a little kid on the playground and you
would choose an up teams, even little
kids knew when it was getting to,
when it was not on an hour. This is not
going to, there's no competition here.
Even as kids,
you knew this,
the warriors are doing right now.
They're doing something that
even children know are wrong.
Even children would break that up.
You don't even really think it is.
I think stern left the NBA. Maybe that's
what it is. Maybe he would've stepped in.
Who knows? I always thought that that
guy was shady. Um, I do know this.
Without a doubt,
Cleveland's gonna win a fucking game
because the NBA does not make money is
nearly as much money on a four game
series versus five, six, seven.
So at some point I'm looking for them
to fucking just start calling everything
on the warriors. But then again, I am a
fucking conspiracy theory. Fucking freak.
Um, I dunno. I still feel like the cavs
and not played their best game yet.
All right. I'm going to say they're
going to win game three. Fuck it.
I'm putting it out there. All right. Go
fuck yourselves. I'll see you on Thursday.